so you guys were just saying this is the
first time in weeks you get to wear
regular clothes
yeah long time and when you're in the
off season of the TV show do you get to
take a break for a bit of the spray
tanning the makeup do you give yourself
a break you never do I'm actually
devastated I feel so white right now I'm
like I need a spray tan it's gonna
happen I need a Christmas glow but no on
the tour we usually get spray tans the
thing is when you get into this space
and then you start Dirty Dancing you
kind of you need it on tanning yourself
how do you guys actually do that on the
road vote Dean is there a portable ten
oh it's disgusting but so basically
we'll go like every seven days and some
awesome person in the city that we're at
will come after the show to the venue
spray tan us we'll have to sleep in our
bunk beds and get them all disgusting
and then our wonderful drivers will wash
our sheets that night but Wow oh yeah
it's to have the full Dancing with the
Stars experience so if we don't have a
spray tan yeah is it Dancing with the
Stars I think not yeah I think you have
to stay true to form um what is also
great about this tour is there's so many
couples at this point like everybody's
wife DUP everybody's married have you
guys ever done a tour together as a
married couple or is this your first one
this is our first we were engaged last
year yes and we were planning a wedding
and that was very stressful so I'm
really excited to just relax as a
married couple that's what I wanted to
ask is how will this be do you it's a
lot of time together this is not
exemplar Latorre
relaxation for married couples are
rarely recommended how do you guys do
when you're it's a lot of time together
I love the time together it's just know
together I'd rather be you know
backpacking through Europe yes then we
don't even get a sleep in the same bed
how does this work well the bunk beds
yeah until my arm like falls asleep and
then right goodnight I'm gonna pick it
out and go to my bunk bed is that really
what you guys do oh yeah I mean
when I tell you that they're like this
big it's really hard and it's sweaty
imagine we're like upset I mean you know
argument sometimes and we late like go
to your buck but tour bus is not built
for married couples marry women and now
I'm picturing that you're you're okay
yeah yeah so he's above me okay I have
to sleep on the bottom bunk I'm just
like okay and then do you just know
there's no bunk space it's not it's not
that romantic okay
a bus yeah it doesn't sound it and are
all the couples on one bus together or
is it all split up uh it just depends
usually you stay with your person it'd
be weird if I was like I'm on a
different bus but yeah like is it like
is there a couple's bus no no no okay we
mix it up okay we were doing the math I
think at this point our Brendan and I
really now and the only single people
yeah yeah Brandon Allen are the only
single people we were talking about this
actually this past season all of the
girls were married it was the first
season that all the girls are married
and then we have some straggler boys
they got to get their lives together I
think
can you set them up with somebody how is
it maybe they have their lives together
no you know it's I look at things yeah
we're gonna decide well we'll figure it
out for them now that I've heard these
logistics this doesn't seem as likely
but a beautiful first would be a baby
that was made on Dancing with the Stars
tour well it's a little difficult
anything they should be made on there's
a lot of dance and a lot of love havin a
log to your mind I love it got my first
for television isn't about you guys I
feel like there's not much like you
never seem TMI to me I feel like you'll
talk about anything you're like yeah I
want to baby I'll smoking on the bus
yeah like you just so you guys are gonna
make love work on the dish with the
Stars tour buses is there one couple
that is the most PD a couple of all of
you guys
I don't know I'm gonna saw some pretty
PDA where maybe if you consider this PDA
splat my but we're pretty PDA but yeah
that's we're kind of like subtly PDA you
know that wasn't that subtle yeah well
no I would never do that I'm saying
we're more of like a just make out like
another couple degrees okay well Whitney
I just wiped up dancing the Stars has
made some beautiful love connections
happen you're gonna have the champs on
the tour Hannah and Alan yeah how do you
guys think all the celebrities will
handle the tour like who's maybe the
most prepared who's the least what do
you think I think they'll all love it
yeah I'm excited for them I think it's
great that you know Dancing with the
Stars in it as an experience is probably
one of the best things anyone can do
honestly I think it's just the most
beautiful experience but the competition
element even though it's a lot of fun
for us as spectators you know for the
people involved in the show that's a
real big kind of like hiccup in the
harmony of everyone's love for one
another because the truth is there's
still competition on tour we don't have
that every celebrity is gonna feel like
they're part of the family they're gonna
feel loved and accepted it's more
enjoyable judgement all the time no but
I'm not letting so we're gonna have the
rivalry
I did hear though that there's a rivalry
with ping pong playing thank goodness
there's no ping pong table on the tour
bus because these boys are pretty
obsessed who every every water break we
get there is a full-on tournament going
on outside but it's it's not about ping
pong as much as it is about engaging in
competition so what we lack with you're
not having the show so you got to have a
winner and loser ping pong please it
could be rock-paper-scissors we had
bottle for than at intermission
like well I wish there was a show behind
the scenes
of the tour of the tour because it's a
very different experience who's the best
player in ping-pong yeah it fluctuates
you know it's like the stock market at
the moment I would say Gleb Savchenko
stock as a ping-pong table champion is
quite obvious everybody has said on the
rise I'm a strong second okay who's the
biggest prankster Sasha Sasha yeah who
is the biggest diva wanna say Sasha
Sasha kind of like monopolized that
claim you know so he kind of like took
that value you want all the titles
you're like I'm coming oh you're I feel
like Allen's gonna be so focused I'm
just carrying that mirror ball with him
everywhere yeah yeah tip-top shape no I
would say Sasha who's the biggest diva
give me a couple names it doesn't get
one person I will say this we all are
it's a gender and it rhymes with boys
wow wow all right your answer there was
clear everybody has said the guys are
worse because let me tell you okay so
the girls I last year I had I think a
22nd change a 22nd quick change I had a
change full outfit and shoes the guys
over here they would so we have a
wardrobe person with us in our changing
room this girl poor girl has to put on
their socks
Gleb definitely had her put on his socks
Laura oh yeah they're pretty much divas
so it's good and last question for you
guys
while the tour is happening with me diva
is
so diva is a version of great dance
don't think you guys are saying the lab
yeah but we have a name with great
ping-pong skills big attitude that's
right okay
while the tour is happening the new
season of The Bachelor will be airing
and Hannah is on it so will you watch it
will you watch it with Hannah will you
press her fur I'm excited to get the
inside scoop I will be honest one of my
favorite parts of having Joe grocery
store Joe as my partner is I got the
inside scoop on a lot of things for any
bachelor fan oh is a dream I was like
that makes sense
to get some inside scoop hopefully okay
yeah I'm we're again the girls that's
our favorite thing we have we have days
off on Monday and our favorite thing is
to watch the show together so the last
question how do you guys get a little
time to yourself do you sneak off for a
date night like amidst all the touring
[Music]
we make sure that on our days off that
we do have either like a little LAN
should we do something together yeah
that was really good about wanting to
see the cities which I would rather stay
in bed all day but he's really good
about getting me out of the hotel and
walking around seeing a museum or seeing
this oh yeah make sure to do that
awesome
real people and is this true the most
celebrities ever on the tour this time
yes very exciting how do you you got you
got Allen Sasha
Brandon all the celebs yeah all of them
perfect this is most celebs that we've
ever had so it's crazy everyone gets one
of my favorites
[Music]